uh thought came over and criticized the
scientific method and we're probably
going to get to the word existence with
him as well uh eventually
but uh this time around he talked about
something else he talked about what is
it the uh falsifiability and uh the fact
that you need um to evidence some kind
of evidence i guess he was thinking of
some kind of experiment or something
okay so here let me turn him on this is
uh
this is what he said
go let's go slowly here
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
what does it mean to say that a theory
is rational
and
does the rationality of an explanation
depend on falsifiability and evidence
and when it comes to a rational theory
i'd say that a rational theory would
have to be falsifiable and consistent
with evidence if it does not fit any of
those two criteria then it is irrational
okay
so uh he thinks it's all
related to falsifiability
and um evidence
but as we just covered it a minute ago a
falsifiability has to do with belief and
evidence has to do with belief and
belief is not science belief is religion
so obviously this poor fellow you know
he was educated in a monastery somewhere
you know he learned all this i guess
from the priests and you know that's the
best i can think of because why would he
talk about falsifiability and um
and evidence you know uh you know when a
prosecutor tries to convince you he
presents you know evidence to the juror
to you you know if you're the juror and
he's just trying to convince you
so he presents evidence and if you
believe the evidence yeah you sign up to
you vote for his case you know none of
that has anything to do with science uh
legal world is all religion it's all
about belief how many people have been
sentenced uh erroneously among
me
yeah a lot of people get sent to the
death chamber you know and it turns out
they were innocent they found out years
later that the guy had nothing to do
with it but the juror believed the
theory despite that later on they found
out true evidence referred or evidence
that the guy was innocent so it was a
fact when he went to prison
and then he found out it was not a fact
that there's a different fact so we have
all these facts
all these beliefs they're known as
beliefs
okay so let's look at this father he
says falsifiability okay here it is we
look it up it says falsifiable able to
be proven false okay what is false not
true
okay uh it was proved to establish the
truth by evidence or argument
and what is true well conformity with
fact or reality not false
what's truth a verified or indisputable
fact what is fact something that
actually exists reality truth
reality the state of qua or quality of
being real uh
and what is real it's true look it up
it's got to do with truth and finally we
have evidence that which tends to prove
or disprove right to whom i don't know
maybe to the pope something ground for
belief yes
proof so all we did was just go around
in circle all he had was synonym we
don't know what falsifiability means
because it's got to do with uh proving
something false and all those are
synonyms so we have no idea what this
fellow poor fellow is talking about and
so i have to believe that you know maybe
just maybe
um
this fellow didn't use his brain very
much in in school or
monastery i don't know where he where he
went you know and uh you know i don't
think he used his cpu very much i think
he used his rom his random
his read-only memory i'm sorry read-only
memory that's all he's got just
memorized all this stuff in in school he
had no use for his brain apparently just
sat and warmed the desk and received
this you know by word of mouth that's it
he just listened to it and he never
uh
analyzed it
on his own he never criticized he never
attacked it he just accepted himself on
the basis of what authority okay so this
is how these people work
and yeah what can i say
again rationality here we have it for
those who are interested what is
irrational well treating concepts as
objects that's what rationality is
rationality has nothing to do or
irrationality has nothing to do with um
you know verifying or or falsifying we
don't falsify anything in science we try
not to it's the other way around we try
to
you know unfalsify things you know not
falsify them and we certainly don't use
evidence because evidence is just there
to convince you no irrational means that
you're going to move concepts around
such as you know time dilation you know
you're going to dilate time
that's scary stuff and you're going to
go with a force you know
transfer the energy
weigh the mass
yeah that's a primary one the first one
there but then you know you're using
inconsistent definitions or undefined
words which is just about all the words
in mathematics
are all undefined they finally say well
words you need more words to define
those words and those words need to be
defined as well so we cannot define any
word that's their answer it's just uh
circular or infinite as they said
infinite argument and so they never
define words and they're satisfied with
that they say yeah you gotta the bug has
to stop somewhere but it doesn't then it
just goes on and on and on so we don't
define any words and they have no
definition for any of those words
no look up field field is defined as a
value at each point in space
and then they say the field moved the
charge
what do you mean the field move the
charges like a paddle you know
no you can't do that charge is a is a
number 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19
coulombs right that that's the value of
a charge and you're going to move this
number with this paddle called a field a
bunch of numbers a bunch of values
at each point in space
no you're not allowed to do that that's
known as irrationality
you